Will a vacuum chamber float on water or sink and what will happen when you crack the vacuum chamber underwater
Well Maxament. I think we've come up with a good way to make some small disposable vacuum chambers. So let's try it out
Rather than using a full-size vacuum chamber and putting it into say a large tub of water or swimming pool
We're gonna see if we can't make a very small vacuum container, just using a soda bottle. Here's the basic idea:
We're going to empty out our soda bottle, drill a small hole into the lid and add a rubber stopper
We'll put the whole bottle and stopper inside of a vacuum chamber and suck all of the air out
The stopper should prevent any air rushing back into our bottle, at which point we can see how well it floats on water
compared to a bottle full of air
the first step in turning our little soda bottle here into a vacuum chamber is of course going to be emptying out what's already in it
Cream soda guys
One more thing that I do want to do just to see if we're getting our vacuum is
I'm gonna drop a marshmallow down into this bottle. So it won't have a complete vacuum
It'll be a vacuum with a marshmallow in it
But I think that will really help us see whether or not we're getting the effect. We want this piece of tape
It's gonna be pretty loose. You can't really see it
But there should be just enough space for air to escape out of the bottle. All right time to fire this up
Give it a test
Let's take our entire bottle with the modified lid
Place it inside our vacuum chamber and let's drop one more
Marshmallow down into that vacuum chamber so we can see the difference between the two, pull out all the air and see what happens.
I spy two expanding marshmallows. Just what I was hoping to see. Think we've got a pretty good vacuum
Now let's see what happens if we add air back in
That marshmallow doesn't look as squished down as this one did so I think we did manage to keep a vacuum in there
In fact, I'm gonna pull up on the rubber and see if the marshmallow changes. Oh
Definitely, so, we did have a vacuum in there and then I broke the seal and now we don't have a vacuum in there
It's just full of air and a marshmallow again. So we confirmed that it does hold a vacuum or at least lower pressure
It might not be a complete vacuum, but it's much closer than it is now
You can see how squished that marshmallow got. Poor guy. Same thing one more time this time though
We just aren't going to break the seal as long as it looks like everything is working
I'm gonna put another layer of tape over it to really hold down the rubber seal. Hopefully that'll prevent any leaks
You know, I am providing lateral stabilization
Trying to hold the bottle from falling over but I am not holding it up at all
In fact, even if I push it down under the water you can see that it pops back up quickly.
So, confirmed. A vacuum chamber does float on water
well, I didn't actually think that a bottle with a vacuum in it was going to sink when we think about a bottle floating we
Think about the air inside of it being what keeps it afloat
what really makes the difference is whether the total density of a bottle and
Whatever it contains is higher or lower than the total density of the water that it
displaces the bottle full of air weighs less than the same volume of water
A bottle full of vacuum actually weighs even less than that
We don't really think of air as having much weight
But it does have mass it's mostly made of nitrogen oxygen and a little bit of carbon dioxide and some other trace elements
That air while very lightweight to us does have some mass to it
However, we were able to test and confirm that a bottle with a vacuum in
it does float on water and now it's time to move on to the second part of the common request which is to see what
Happens if you break a vacuum chamber underwater. Well, once again, I think they mean while it has a vacuum
So let's pull all the air out of our bottle once again, and then try and crack it underwater
poor marshmallow friend has now been inflated and deflated and re-inflated and
(Sighs) That’s tough
Oh, that's so cool
Yeah water is just
spraying in there super fast
Yeah, It's kind of cool because those bubbles are a vacuum that are just surrounded by water and as the water
fills in all the spaces they are dissipating
not all of them are vacuum though because some of them stay and are starting to float up toward the surface
Maxament, Thank you for your suggestions
this has been great to
experiment with in fact that looked so cool that I think we're gonna have to scale that up and maybe do one of our
Full-size vacuum jars just get all the water on
It find a.. maybe aswimming pool or something at least a really big container of water
And something where I can get a lot more momentum and just whack it with a hammer
Get it to really crack open all once maybe do that a few different times. I don't know. This is really cool
Check your youtube inbox. We are sending you 25 bucks
and remember if you've got a cool idea of something you want to see us do let us know down in the comments if we
Use your idea. We'll send you 25 bucks
Hey guys. Thanks for watching
If you're not a subscriber yet just hit the bomb to get in the club if you missed our last video or want to watch
It again just click up here at the top click down there if you want to see what the internet thinks that you should watch
Next that's it for now. Have fun. Be safe and see you tomorrow